[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
here come back come back
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we
[Applause]
[Music]
governor cuomo
[Music]
[Music]
resigned
[Applause]
[Music]
guys
join us
[Music]
hey
well i mean i think in a state like new
york that has some of the strictest
anti-harassment laws
uh to watch our executive cross the line
again and again
you know anyone who works in new york
knows don't even approach the great area
and to see our executives so frequently
cross the line it's really disgusting
to see aside from his politics which i
disagree with
i think he needs to resign
i don't think we need any more
investigation i think we have three
reliable accounts um
[Music]
and i i think that is evidence enough
and
we don't need to even wait an
investigation no more questions we ask
why are we doubting the integrity of
these women
my name is matt sickles
that's ickless
come around and join us what's up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
out yes we all know why we're here
my name is sumathi kumar i'm with the
new york city democratic socialists of
america
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
like i said we all know why we're here
today right
very good
[Applause]
yesterday the third woman sopha
came out um accusing governor cuomo of
sexual harassment
and inappropriate behavior we know that
where there's three
there's more right that's right
these things are not isolated incidents
and as a young woman of color myself
working in politics
i feel so much solidarity with the brave
woman who comes
forward so far it takes courage
and we have all experienced
[Applause]
[Music]
we have all been in situations i think
where people in power men in power
have tried to use their position to take
advantage
of young women of anybody who's below
them
in terms of power and it's not okay
so today we are here because cuomo
has proven that he is not fit
to govern our state new yorkers
deserve better
[Applause]
and we've known this for a while right
we've known this not just in the way he
interacts with people interpersonally
but the way that he governs
this is the same governor who cut
medicaid
at the height of a
[Music]
[Applause]
the same pandemic who has covered up
thousands of nursing home deaths
and left family members without a clue
about their loved ones
this is the same governor who's trying
to push
yet another austerity budget on new
yorkers
during an economic disaster the likes of
which we have not seen
in our lifetimes
so it stands to remain that someone who
governed so cruelly
would act the same way in interpersonal
situations
and we are not okay with that that is
not the way
that new york should be governed that is
not the leadership
that new yorkers need right now we need
a compassionate
approach not a cruel one we need
people who are going to stand up for the
most vulnerable
not push them down manipulate them
and harass them and so we are together
today
calling for governor cuomo to resign
immediately
[Music]
[Music]
yes s u m
a t h y
k u m a r u r
[Music]
[Applause]
jake my name is jonathan
i'm with new york communities for change
[Music]
we are in month 12
[Music]
of a pandemic
that governor cuomo has been presiding
over
has been presiding over in 12 months
we have not seen any relief
for our people for our people who can't
pay rent who can't put food on the table
who are going homeless
and our governor
has been spending that pandemic
sexually harassing
young women and also
also covering up the
thousands of deaths and thousands that
have gone
unreported of
nursing home residence
and it covered it up
this is the governor that many of us
have known for the past
decade this is nothing new
this is nothing new this is who he is
this is who he is he serves his donors
he serves his daughter and not the
people not
the people and it is now
finally being paid attention to
by so many other people so many other
people
what we have known all along
so we are left with one demand
[Music]
and that demand is resigned
[Applause]
[Music]
ricky silver thank you
empire state indivisible i'm here today
to stand in solidarity with everyone
here and everyone that couldn't make it
who's calling for the governor to resign
for one simple fact
this governor has spent a decade abusing
his power
these allegations which are incredibly
atrocious difficult to read
difficult to imagine
are just another reminder of a decade of
abusive
combative and terrible behavior
by the governor of the state we have
heard it from legislators calling on him
calling on him to resign we have called
uh heard from
activists and those directly impacted
and we are here
standing with them today in support of
those calls
make no mistake an independent
investigation
must go forward regardless of whether
the governor resigns or not
an investigation is needed for
accountability
his resignation is needed for new york
we are a month away from the new york
state budget being due
the most consequential budget in decades
with a pandemic still raging and a
recovery
that has never started millions of new
yorkers have been left
to fend for themselves hungry
homeless terrified afraid
and this governor continues throughout
the pandemic
to push for budget cuts
no relief and even worse
panders to his billionaire and
millionaire donors
as if their luxury and their location of
residence
is going to matter guess what they're
not going anywhere shame
the billionaire the billionaires in this
state
have made something close to a hundred
billion
new dollars during the pandemic the
least we can do
is end tax breaks on the wealthy yes
sunday just recovery for all
[Applause]
and invest in our new york
[Music]
mistakes well the allegations have come
out are
terrible and we all expect there to be
more
it is the trend it is the sequence of
behavior that shows us exactly who this
man is
a man that will stop at nothing abused
all his power to get what he wants
and we won't stand for it anymore so
thank you
[Applause]
resign
[Music]
because your power your power
has become corrupt has become corrupt
your power
your power has assaulted has assaulted
women women and when that happens
you lose the trust you lose the trust of
all the people
of all the people and so
[Music]
[Applause]
justice
and we will not go
home
thank you
tonight from the democratic socialists
of america
[Applause]
so as a woman who's no longer young in
the workplace
listening to the stories of these brave
women who've come forward
has been in many ways re-traumatizing
bringing to life the experiences i felt
as a young woman in early in my career
knowing that cuomo has perpetrated the
transgression against people in the
workplace is sickening
but it's not just about sexual assault
and the harassment
it's also about the fact that cuomo
governs
by abuse he doesn't just abuse the
people who work with him
he also abuses journalists so
we know that he uses this to disrupt the
democratic process
he makes sure that legislators who don't
agree with him are intimidated
he makes sure journalists are going to
repeat stories that are going to
harm his reputation he calls any bullies
on that night
he doesn't even believe in the freedom
of the press so we say right now
that cuomo it's no longer acceptable for
you to use abuse
and bullying and harassment to take
away from the people of new york the
things that we need we deserve and we
want and that includes
taxing the rich a just budget
adequate policies to deal with this
pandemic and the vulnerabilities that
have been having created as a result so
governor cuomo we're just telling you
nicely
right now to
and i was born in resign and
in california they pass the rich and
they hold
their governors accountable so i'm
already jealous of the weather
you have to be jealous even more of
their politics thank you
[Music]
his
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]